so if you just got to find the right  Square for the king for the bar yeah as  long as the white king moves to safety  somewhere the the white king can step  out of the pin you just need to be able  to move the Knight so which way do you  go with a king this is what Lev is  trying to work out now he's got loads of  time where do you go with the King my  instinct is to go to the middle right up  the board this one yeah  I like it and he's a big threat there's  only one check here as well and that's  the only check that you know it's been  played and he's found it I think this is  the winning I win this night check is  going to dislodge the black king white  is going to make a new Queen game over  if vantrick shakes his head  poor Chucky hands now and he does click  that resign button game over  121 points first can we give a round of  applause for everyone shook wow it's  been so entertaining to have him in this  tournament a legend in Chess at 53 years  old